and howard with the rebound  lebron off the bow lebron say it with  your  [Applause]  chest  [Music]  [Applause]  excellent feed from caruso lebron  running the lane  russell westbrook trying to take the  charge grown man moved wow express  yourself lebron  35 years old yeah javale we saw two  mcgee that pass was coming in a little  hot westbrook on lebron  lebron ate it up at the rim wow he got  some bounce in those 35 year old legs  and through covington county  weight room time lebron with that wide  base  [Music]  couldn't catch good defense by tucker  stood his ground  lebron punches that into the family  section  and he's playing with a sense of urgency  he didn't have his way offensively but  didn't give up on the play  which is so crucial we have seen